[Music]
divvy up in the office do raps I've been
walking through corporate talked about
ownership and Everest 1806 is out of
everything
for example Pokemon if you read crush it
no.9 and you decided to build the blog
which later became the video blog which
later became the podcast around Pokemon
if you became the foremost Pokemon gal
and you just owned it and you're just
getting by and you're trucking along and
then pokemons go comes out the world
would have walked into you instead of
you walking to where the money is
everybody is listening right now is
looking for trends oh these spinners are
cool they're trying to walk to where the
world is now and by the time they get
there the world moved on if you go to
your thing and set a [ __ ] flag on
your thing I genuinely believe that
there's a lot of moments where the world
comes to you through I can't answer that
for you Peter's holding you back you
know what you want to do the only reason
you're not doing is because they're
scared of doing what you actually want
to do okay so when you scared at sailing
still being at the same place when my
friends the next level a huge mistake
you don't want the same thing your
friends want so why the [ __ ] do you care
what they have the fact that you're
worrying about other people's
accomplishments is already a losing
formula you need to get rid of that
first then you can focus on yourself I
am tired of people not starting and
living their life on one very simple
thing which is they're worried about
what other people think are you really
really really not gonna live your life
based on somebody's anonymous buck an
icon feedback that you suck they [ __ ]
suck please take the passion that is
pouring out of my [ __ ] face right now
and run with it and go do something 400
million to one when you understand that
math how can't you live your life that's
how easy it is to be a human being
please squeeze the [ __ ] I'm like go home
cut one cut your userís lose your
friends and go find a winner friends go
like go somewhere confidence and like
hunger it's passed on to each other like
go audit your circle add one more winner
decrease my loser defense is shorter
offense ironically is longer you only
know you're on the right path when the
things that you want to be happening are
actually starting to happen and usually
people give up before they happen or
they'll never get there and it's
extremely difficult to dissect
generally very easy if you dissect
deeply right I think a lot of people
talk about luck and when you're somebody
like me like you work a lot in lives
that make sure it's hard to accept luck
but there's no question things like
being able to immigrant out of a Soviet
Union or having a mother that is so
insanely amazing
you know I didn't control that you can't
fake environment so if you gather
yourself with people who are from a
certain cloth or have a certain hunger
or have a certain point of view very
quickly that rubs off on you breaking
your patterns is extremely difficult and
but if you're unhappy with your
situation you've got to change a pattern
[Music]
it's all I've got
it's all I've got you know you're the
best thing I'm really you know we you
know what's funny to say about that I
really do think I'm really good at being
mean and by the way it's what I'm
attracted to and others when you're all
the way you yeah people know it when
you're all the way you people know it
it's important it you know the cliche
terms are authenticity and other things
of that nature
season beyond that it's just being
it's just being like it's almost like
being one with yourself like I never
have any doubt about my intent about how
it ends up and and about the market
adjusting if I lose badly I don't have
any doubt that that's what should have
happened
I respect the market as much as I
respect myself and then I adjust to the
reality of it the end you know I didn't
rush here at all everybody's been
pushing me to Asia for [ __ ] five seven
nine years I'm like it'll come they'll
come when I feel like it's time to cover
yeah you know and that's a and if I came
six months earlier it would've been too
early because I wouldn't have felt
natural and if I'd never came I would
never come
[Music]
the only thing I care about in the world
is consumer attention
I basically consume no content except
those football games on Sunday I watch
all consumer behavior i watch what they
react to I often look at big data and
try to analyze it but normally I rely on
my intuitive nature and most of all I'm
completely unemotional about what's
actually happening if it is a threat to
it of what I'm doing then that makes me
happy not upset because I'd much rather
put myself out of business than have
somebody else do it for me
[Music]
because it see a lot of people ask on
Twitter can you build a successful
company without working 24 hours a day
of course you can a hundred percent I
think you can I just think that most
people aren't talented enough to not
work a lot so I'm scared that people
think they can work five hours and build
a successful company but like Jason
freed and like 37signals like all
automated all like there's a lot of ways
to win i absolutely believe that's the
case I'm a fan of working hard if you
want the audacity to have a business
that pays for your entire livelihood I
feel like it's controllable
[Music]
karma is practical
eleven people - Karma's like kissing
your fingers doing good for other people
is a good strategy like I like it's like
you know I've been like trying to
predict I'm like why is this thing even
exists it's actually the most common
sense thing of all time why is karma
seem weird the [ __ ] is karma like wait a
minute so you're telling me like if you
do lots of good things good things
happen to you
[Music]
[Music]
self-awareness is number one you have to
know who you are if you do not know who
you are you'll play a game that doesn't
benefit you empathy
um I think that the more I think about
my life I think my my real deep
intuitive nature of being empathetic has
never allowed me to be disappointed
and then number three is the one thing
that I think is unbelievably
controllable is work ethic
I just don't know anybody who's ever
really made it for themselves and I want
to inspire entrepreneurs there's a lot
of 18 16 20 to 24 year old people who
think you have to fake it to you make it
who think that you have to kill the
other guy to get yours there's so much
for everybody
I want my legacy to be that I just built
the biggest building in town and I want
to inspire up-and-coming entrepreneurs
to be kind people and assassins and
killers and building their business I
don't think people realize no matter
what you're doing if you're at zero and
you're in the middle of nowhere or
you're a trillion and on a high-rise in
New York you've got your perspective
like there's a lot of people right like
like you got your perspective and you
just need to own that
got nothing I live with this this but
this how I see it I have immigrants
parents from India there's how we see
culture like like you never know like
everybody everybody's doubting
themselves instead of thinking about
what do I I have my perspective I have
my ear to the streets in this little
block this is what I know so everybody
just sitting right now listening about
what they're not instead of realizing
what they are for me it's gratitude I'm
super grateful man like I was born in
the [ __ ] place got out of Russia when
nobody was getting out right like like
I'm grateful like if I wake up and
everybody my family is alive I'm so
[ __ ] fired up I don't want [ __ ] I
don't listen
[ __ ] I'm just like I'm so grateful you
need to be aware of when you have your
big opportunities you squeeze so [ __ ]
hard when you've got that moment you
have to understand that [ __ ] will always
change if it's terrible right now it's
going to get better if it is phenomenal
right now it is going to get worse that
is just the way it's always been
it's not smart it's just [ __ ] history
it's about time recognize your moments
and strike that has absolutely been the
foundation of my success whether it was
selling my baseball cards when I just
felt it whether it was the Internet
itself whether it was other things like
starting vaynermedia when I had all
these other opportunities but I wanted
to triple down on my strengths during
this golden era sometimes they're fun
sometimes they're taking a step back in
theory but it's all about knowing when
to go all-in and the one thing we get is
regret when we didn't squeeze our best
opportunity so when you're a football
player at USC that is a big-time [ __ ]
opportunity because most of you don't go
to the league and most of you aren't
successful in the league and this is
your apex and whether you're a manager
in a store right now whether you're a
great student in high school whether
you're awfully pretty right now but you
know you're not gonna be as pretty one
day I'm being serious now I know this is
silly [ __ ] but when you have your best
situation when you have the [ __ ]
leverage you need to [ __ ] strike and
when you don't you don't pout you put in
the work to rebuild your next leverage I
had you two
I had Twitter and when they weren't as
big anymore I didn't cry that Instagram
or snapchat came I put in the work to
build myself back up and matter in that
ecosystem and now that I've got the
Instagram moment again I'm [ __ ]
pounding and pounding harder than the
last time because I learned because when
pattern recognition from experience you
get better and so if this can inspire
you if your shits good right now
quadruple down and if it's not stay
quiet and build and look for that moment
when you know it's good pound because
squeezing when you have the opportunity
is the key
[Music]